[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo ihr lieben und herzlich willkommen
zu unserer heutigen Ausgabe ich bin Toni
Heyer und ich bin Mirco Casimir und
heute haben wir einen Fall der
Jahrzehnte alte Ängste bestätigt nämlich
einen Mord an einer Anhalterin Mirko
bist du schon mal getrennt
getrimmt nicht aber ich habe über einen
sehr langen Zeitraum die
Mitfahrgelegenheit genutzt sowas wie
uber oder blablacar genau ober blablacar
Mitfahrzentrale genau so was ja also ich
muss sagen ich bin noch nie getrampt
weil Gott sei Dank meine Mama mir immer
eingebläutert nicht mit Fremden
mitfahren lieber das Geld in Taxi
investieren und sicher zu Hause ankommen
und wenn ich kein Geld zu Hause habe
dann nachts reingehen und an ihren
Geldbeutel und da das Geld rausnehmen
deswegen hatte ich da immer schon ein
bisschen Respekt davor aber ich glaube
du auch ein bisschen älter als ich ich
glaube früher war das auch ein bisschen
normaler zu treffen was heißt hier
früher bitte dich was heißt dir früher
also ich finde ich habe sehr lange die
Mitfahrgelegenheit genutzt oder
blablacar und muss sagen dass es einfach
ein sehr sehr gutes System ist du weißt
mit wem du mitfährst du kannst eine
Bewertung sehen du kannst eine Bewertung
abgeben es ist also eigentlich alles
sehr gut kontrolliert und du kannst im
Vorfeld rein theoretisch schon aus
sieben wenn du als Mitfahrer haben
möchtest oder nicht oder bei welchem
Fahrer oder Fahrerin du mitfahren
möchtest also das ist eigentlich ein
relativ gutes System aber dieses
klassische trampen von wegen ich stelle
mich an die Straße hat meinen Daumen hin
oder ein Schild das muss ich auch sagen
als Kind habe ich das schon noch ein
paar mal gesehen wenn wir so in Urlaub
gefahren sind aber mittlerweile auch gar
nicht mehr also irgendwie habe ich das
Gefühl das ist gar nicht mehr so das
Ding weil es vielleicht auch so viele
günstige Angebote gibt die einfach
wesentlich sicherer sind bevor wir euch
jetzt hier das Ohr abhauen zu den
riesigen das trampens kommen wir später
noch mal wir steigen jetzt in unseren
Fall ein den Mord an Sophia lösche sie
starb im Juni 2018 nachdem sie per
Anhalter mit einem LKW unterwegs war
erstmal lernen wir die Familie kennen
[Musik]
Sophia lösche kommt am 17 februar 1990
in Amberg in der Oberpfalz zur Welt und
wächst auf in einer Sozial- und
politisch engagierten Familie ihr Vater
Johannes lösche ist Pfarrer ihr älterer
Bruder Andreas macht sich einen Namen
als Kulturmanager und Politiker der
Grünen Schwester Katharina arbeitet als
Museumspädagogin Sophia wächst in
pommelsbrunnen bei Nürnberg auf als die
15 ist sieht die Familie wieder nach
Amberg in dieser Stadt macht sie 2010
auch ihr Abi sie studiert danach in
Bamberg Germanistik und macht ihren
Bachelor für den Master zieht sie dann
2015 nach Leipzig schon seit ihre
Schulzeit engagiert sich Sophia
politisch als Schülersprecherin setzt
sie sich gegen Rassismus ein an der Uni
Bamberg arbeitet sie in der
Studentenvertretung mit und fördert die
Abschaffung von Studiengebühren und
ebenfalls im Bamberg kann die dirzi für
die SPD für den Stadtrat und was man
auch erwähnen sollte in den Jahren 2016
bis 2018 reißt sie mehrmals nach Lesbos
um dort in der Gruppe no border kitchen
Flüchtlinge zu unterstützen also sophia
ist eine junge Frau die sicher eine sehr
spannende Zukunft vor sich hat und
übelst engagiert ist wir gehen jetzt
aber erstmal ein bisschen in der Zeit
voraus und zwar zum Juni 2018
der 14 Juni 2018 ist ein milder
Donnerstagabend Sophia besucht noch ein
Seminar an ihrer Uni in Leipzig dann
will sie in die Heimat nach Amberg
fahren ihr Vater feiert am nächsten Tag
Geburtstag sie stellt sich an die
Tankstelle am Autohof Schkeuditz West
hier stehen oft Tramper die Richtung
Süden wollen
Sophia spricht einige Autofahrer an aber
keiner will sie mitnehmen dann kommt
bouchema l er stellt sich freundlich vor
sagt sein Spitzname sei Bob die beiden
unterhalten sich mehr schlecht als recht
auf Deutsch Englisch und Arabisch Sophia
steigt in den blauen 40 Tonner Modell
Renault t460 um 18:14 Uhr fahren Sie ab
aber bevor es jetzt auf die Autobahn 9
Richtung Bayern geht frieren wir das
Bild mal ein
wir stoppen den LKW beim Anfahren und
schauen auf bushma L der Fernfahrer hat
dunkles Haar dass er wegen der lichten
Stellen vorn und hinten Raspel kurz
schneiden lässt auch sein Vollbad ist
meist kurz geschnitten L hat einen eher
schmalen Kopf ist wieder dick noch dünn
vor allem aber ist dieser Typ eine
tickende Zeitbombe mit seiner Frau in
Marokko hat er drei Töchter und einen
Sohn aber die er die ist total kaputt
wie später deutlich wird hat schon mal
auf seine Frau eingestochen das wurde
aber als Unfall im Haus vermeldet und
hatte deswegen auch keine Folgen l Gerät
nach eigener Einschätzung sehr leicht in
Rage und an diesem 14 Juni 2018 ist der
Mann ich versuche es vorsichtig zu
formulieren von einem gesteigerten
sexuellen Verlangen getrieben
wollte man es direkt da sagen würde man
wohl von notgeil sprechen schon am
Vortag hat er Frauen vor einer
autobahntoilette fotografiert und bevor
er Sophia mitnimmt macht er mit dem
Handy Bilder von seinem erigierten Penis
kaputter Typ aber Sophia weiß von dem
allen nichts wir lassen das Bild wieder
laufen
der Lkw der Spedition bentrans fährt
wieder auf der A9 Richtung Süden
vielleicht erklärt er ihr jetzt wie
seine Pläne Aussehen er soll ein
verschiedenen Stationen in Süd- und
Mitteleuropa Maschinen Zubehör einladen
und nach Marokko bringen geplante Stops
in Deutschland sind noch Lauf an der
Pegnitz und Lechhausen bei Augsburg um
19:44 Uhr schreibt Sophia eine
whatsapp-nachricht an eine Freundin
Trampe gerade mit Bob einem
marokkanischen Trucker von Leipzig nach
Amberg er hat mir eine marokkanische
Pfeife geschenkt dazu vier Smileys
wenige Minuten später steuert l die
Raststätte Berg an der A9 an er lädt
Sophia zu einem Espresso ein geht
außerdem aufs Klo eine
Überwachungskamera auf der Anlage filmt
die beiden noch um 19:52 Uhr man sieht
Sophia ausgelassen an der Beifahrerseite
des Renault Lasters sie gibt buschmar
die Schlüssel um kurz nach 9 Uhr an
diesem Abend hält der LKW laut den GPS
auf des bordsystems auf dem Parkplatz
sperbes-ost südlich von Bayreuth an er
bleibt knapp drei Stunden dort stehen
Sophias Vater versucht um 21.45 Uhr sie
auf dem Handy zu erreichen aber es geht
niemand dran 0 Uhr in der Tankstelle
Lauf kauft Buschmann L2 Dosen Becks und
eine Schachtel Marlboro eine der Dosen
wird später mit Sophias Fingerabdrücken
auf dem Gelände der Tanke gefunden über
Nacht gibt es kein Lebenszeichen von
Sophia am nächsten Morgen um 7:45 Uhr
ruft ihr Vater Johannes bei der
Einsatzzentrale der Polizei in
Regensburg an wird aber vertröstet um
10:45 Uhr meldet er sich nochmals und
wird an die Polizei am Berg verwiesen um
11:40 Uhr wird er endlich ausführlich
angehört naja also die Polizei
bekleckert sich nicht mit Ruhm das kann
man jetzt schon absehen und das
bestätigen später auch Recherchen des
ZDF Magazins frontal
die Dienststellen in Leipzig und Amberg
schieben die Zuständigkeit erstmal hin
und her ihre Familie fängt stattdessen
jetzt selber an zu recherchieren sie
geht ganz früh von einem Verbrechen aus
macht sogar die Spedition des
Fernfahrers ausfindig recherchiert im
Internet aber weiter im minutenprotokoll
Mirko wir befinden uns jetzt wieder am
Tag nach dem Aufbruch also am
15.06.2018 dieser 15.06 das muss ja
jetzt der Geburtstag ihres Vaters
gewesen sein
wuschmael hat inzwischen in Lauf an der
Pegnitz Elektroteile geladen also rund
50 km von Sophias Zielort am Berg
entfernt aber von ihr gibt es schon zu
diesem Zeitpunkt kein Lebenszeichen mehr
keine Nachrichten oder gar Sichtungen l
fährt weiter und erreicht am Abend
Frankreich am nächsten Tag wird die
Polizei Leipzig endlich aktiv das ist
jetzt der Samstag also der 16 Juni am
späten Nachmittag stellt die Kripo an
der Autobahnraststätte die
Videoaufnahmen sicher auf denen das
Kennzeichen des Lasters zu sehen ist
damit können jetzt auch Daten der
mautabrechnung gecheckt werden Familie
lösche war wieder schneller sie verteilt
längst Flugblätter und postet
Suchaufrufe über Facebook und buschma L
am Sonntag hält er für lange Zeit an
einem Rastplatz in der Nähe von Bordeaux
er muss das Sonntagsfahrverbot abwarten
er kauft dort außerdem Benzin für rund 6
€. der folgende Tag ist gleich in
zweierlei Hinsicht sehr bedeutend für
den Fall denn an diesem Montag morgens
um 5:13 Uhr hält l im spanischen
Baskenland in der Nähe einer Tankstelle
wirft Sophias gleiche ins Gebüsch und
zündet sie mit Benzin an und am
Nachmittag desselben Tages zeigt sich
auf sehr eindrückliche Weise wie Sophias
Umfeld bei der Suche nach ihr die Zügel
in der Hand hält und die Polizei dabei
ziemlich alt aussehen lässt
denn um 14 Uhr 36 klingelt bushma 11
Handy eine Freundin von Sophie heißt
dran also Stopp mal das muss man sich
kurz vorstellen die Polizei wertet
irgendwelche Daten noch aus und Sophias
Leute rufen mal eben den Täter an aber
ich glaube das zeigt auch ganz
eindrücklich fast vier riesige Sorgen
die sich gemacht haben müssen die beiden
sprechen Französisch miteinander l
bestätigt dass er Sophia mitgenommen hat
aber er beteuert er habe sie an der
Auffahrt 49 bei Lauf rausgelassen die
Freundin stellt Kontakt zwischen L und
der Polizei her der Fernfahrer schickt
sogar ein Foto von sich an die deutschen
Ermittler aber die Uhr tickt jetzt gegen
den Mörder und das obwohl er verzweifelt
versucht seine Spuren zu beseitigen 19
Juni 2018 4:20 Uhr an der Ausfahrt 275
bei carboneros brennt der
ben-translastwagen aus
das ist etwa auf halber Strecke zwischen
Madrid und Gibraltar die spanische
Polizei glaubt bushmael zunächst dass es
hier einen technischen Defekt gab aber
die europäische Zusammenarbeit
funktioniert aus Leipzig kommt ein
Haftbefehl sieben Tage nach dem Sophia
lösche in Leipzig in einen lkw-steg wird
ihre Leiche in der Nähe der Tankstelle
gefunden wo l sie abgelegt und
angezündet hat und aus dem ausgebrannten
LKW also etwa 650 km südlich wird zur
gleichen Zeit der Rest von Sophias
Handtasche geborgen das Feuer hat von
der einstigen Aufschrift kein Mensch ist
illegal nur noch kein Mensch übrig
gelassen die Suche ist zu Ende die
schlimmsten Befürchtungen von Familie
lösche haben sich bewahrheitet
eine junge Frau ist per Anhalter
gefahren und umgebracht worden
buschma el wird nach Deutschland
ausgeliefert aber wann und wo genau ist
Sophia lösche gestorben und die kam es
dazu das ändert zwar nichts mehr am
traurigen Ende dieser Geschichte aber
solche Details sind enorm wichtig für
die Hinterbliebenen entsprechend wurde
der Prozess gegen bushma L mit Spannung
erwartet der Prozess beginnt am 3 juli
2019 vor dem Landgericht Bayreuth die
Staatsanwaltschaft wollte l Mord zur
Verdeckung einer sexuellen Straftat
vorwerfen aber dies lässt sich nicht
eindeutig beweisen und dann liegt Mall
einen hollywood-reifen Auftritt vor
Gerichten das hat die Sächsische Zeitung
so aufgeschrieben
der Auftritt ist filmreif bushma 11
Fleet bitte bringen Sie mich um er
hängen sie mich geben sie meine Organe
an jemanden der sie braucht immer wieder
greift er zum Taschentuch schluchzt und
er streitet unter Tränen ab das ist eine
Vergewaltigung gegeben habe ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich habe da überhaupt gar kein
Mitleid mit ihm also das ist von allem
was wir wissen ein absoluter widerlegen
ich meine er hat ja auch schon auf seine
Frau eingestochen sitzt er im Laster
nimmt ein junges Mädel und er schenkt ja
noch eine Pfeife im Endeffekt war es ein
notgeiler sagt bringt sie um schmeißt
sie einfach wie Müll auf die Straße
zündet sie an und dann sitzt er vor
Gericht und heult und bettelt und flieht
fest steht die Vergewaltigung lässt sich
nicht beweisen und sogar die
Todesumstände sind strittig denn laut
Ermittlungen der deutschen Kripo
eskalierte die Situation schon auf dem
Rastplatz nordöstlich von Nürnberg
dort soll er Sophia belästigt und
begrabscht haben als sie ihn zurückwies
schlug er sie mit einem
Schraubenschlüssel bewusstlos dann
verließ er für etwa 20 Minuten den
Laster dieser Version nach kehrt l dann
wieder zum Renault Laster zurück merkt
dass Sophia noch atmet und schlägt sie
mit dem Schraubenschlüssel tot
die Nebenklage also sophia ist Bruder
Andreas und die Eltern ist überzeugt
dass L Sophia nach den ersten Hieben am
Leben ließ und erst am Sonntag in
Frankreich tötete wenn man da mal so in
die Gerichtsprotokolle guckt dass es
richtig spannend ehrlich gesagt also zum
Beispiel gab es da ja die Bierdose die L
nach Mitternacht in sperrbes gekauft hat
wenn Sophia da schon tot war wie kam
dann ihre Fingerabdrücke da drauf
außerdem musste auch noch diskutiert
werden welche Rolle der lange Transport
nach Frankreich für den Zustand der
Leiche spielte das Gericht sieht es am
Ende als erwiesen an dass Sophia noch in
Deutschland getötet wurde und es
verurteilt am 18 September 2019 zu einer
lebenslangen Freiheitsstrafe wegen
Mordes in Tat Mehrheit mit gefährlicher
Körperverletzung
das alles ist schon unvorstellbar
schrecklich grausam Schlümpfe diese
Familie aber es wird noch unerträglicher
denn Neonazis und Rassisten nutzen den
Fall für ihre Zwecke und missbrauchen
Sofia also sie lassen Ihr Foto auf
Aufkleber drucken und hetzen mit dem
Fall gegen Nordafrikaner die Atmosphäre
ist so vergiftet dass die Trauerfeier
unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit
abgehalten werden muss ja wirklich ein
Fall der ein stark beschäftigt Toni und
dann bleibt er noch das Klischee vom
gefährlichen trampen also dem fahren per
Anhalter jetzt hatten wir am Anfang
schon meine Mama hatte da richtig Panik
davor dass wir das machen und das ist ja
auch irgendwie die Urangst aller Eltern
also dass die Kinder trampen und
irgendwas passiert ich habe da mal ein
bisschen im Internet rum gestöbert und
es hat dazu 1989 und 1995 Studien
gegeben und zwar von der Universität
Wuppertal und vom Bundeskriminalamt und
beide kamen zum Ergebnis dass es
statistisch keine große Gefahr gibt beim
Trampen einem Verbrechen zum Opfer zu
fallen das größte Risiko ist einen
Autounfall zu erleiden okay aber ich
finde dass es sich natürlich trotzdem
komisch anfühlt wenn man einfach mit
einem Fremden mitfährt ja das stimmt
also das hatten wir auch anfangs schon
so ein bisschen
so dieses komplett an die Straße stellen
und zu irgendjemandem einsteigen das ist
ja wirklich ein bisschen sage ich jetzt
mal Russisch Roulette so man weiß
wirklich nicht was passiert es gab ja
aber auch so Tipps das weiß ich jetzt so
aus Erzählungen von meiner Mama die
selbst oft getrennt ist dass man
irgendwie nur zu zweit schreiben oder
sich das nur mein Schild aufschreibt
oder halt jemanden bescheid sagt wo man
dazu gestiegen ist ja aber trampen ist
meiner Meinung nach eh in überholtes
System und vielleicht nur noch wirklich
für Leute interessant die wirklich
absolut kein Geld ausgeben wollen denn
du kannst mit Mitfahrgelegenheit blablac
haben mit 14 zentrale wie die ganzen
Community ist alle hießen und heute noch
heißen natürlich auf Nummer sicher gehen
indem du einfach die Fahrer kennst und
die Mitfahrer kennst und das ganze über
eine zentrale gesteuert wird wo man
jetzt zwar in der gewissen Art und Weise
noch anonym ist aber trotzdem über
gewisse Systeme sich ganz einfach
nachvollziehen fest wer mitfährt oder
wer fährt zum Beispiel heutzutage in
diesen ganzen Apps auch so in der Stadt
wenn du eine Mitfahrgelegenheit brauchst
da gibt es ja auch so viele
Sicherheitsmechanismen die da eingebaut
sind also ich kenne das z.B wenn ich
irgendwo mitfahre und das Auto steht
dann zu lange weil ich z.B gerade ein
Döner Stopp mache
dann ploppt immer automatisch so ein
kleines Fensterchen auf ob bei mir alles
okay ist oder ob ich Hilfe brauche weil
die Fahrt so lange unterbrochen ist und
das ist auf jeden Fall eine positive
Entwicklung das auch einfach mehr
Bewusstsein dafür da ist dass sowas
natürlich auch wenn man die Daten hat
oder das durch einen seriöses
Unternehmen ist da trotzdem einfach noch
was passieren kann und man da wesentlich
aufmerksamer sein muss in Sofia Fall er
hat das natürlich nichts geholfen ich
meine sie ist getrennt und ich kann mir
auch irgendwie vorstellen dass man gar
nicht erwartet dass einem was böses
passiert auch gerade wenn man viele
positive Erfahrungen mit solchen
Mitfahrgelegenheiten oder etc hatte man
erwartet ja nicht dass einem jetzt so
was grausames passiert und die Menschen
so grundlos furchtbar sind das möchte
man vielleicht auch jetzt hier an dieser
Stelle noch mal ganz kurz betonen das
natürlich nicht jeder der eine
Mitfahrgelegenheit anbietet nicht jeder
der einen Tramper mitnimmt oder der
trampt ähm Verbrecher ist das ist ganz
klar das stimmt natürlich nicht wenn man
den wirklich trampen will dann sollte
man wie du schon gesagt hast zur eigenen
Sicherheit ohne geht immer das
Schlimmste vermuten zu wollen einfach so
ein paar Eckpunkte beachten und dann ein
paar Freunde oder die Familie kurz
informieren mit wem man mitfährt wohin
man gerade fährt damit da so ein paar
Dinge auf jeden Fall immer
weitergeleitet werden das könnte eine
gewisse Sicherheit bieten ja aber das
hat so viel tatsächlich auch gemacht sie
hat eine Freundin geschrieben sie ist
mit dem und dem unterwegs in die und die
Richtung aber das ist halt leider auch
die grausame Realität so ich kenne das
auch ich teile mein Standort mit meiner
besten Freundin die kann jederzeit
gucken wo ich bin wenn mir aber wirklich
was passiert dann ist es halt leider
auch schwer von der Ferne irgendwie
einzugreifen oder Hilfe zu holen wenn
dir jemand was Böses tun möchte dann
bist du dem ausgeliefert auch wenn
jemand weiß wo du bist ja in dem Fall
hat es halt einfach nur dazu beigetragen
dass man den Täter nach relativ kurzer
Zeit schnappen konnte ja Gott sei Dank
sophia hat leider nicht geholfen
[Musik]
das war's für heute wir haben den Fall
von Sophia lösche mit den umfangreichen
Recherchen unseres Reporters Jörg
völkerling erzählt sowie berichten von
Merkur sächsischer Zeitung und Südkorea
Script Stefan netzewandt Aufnahme und
schnitt Toni Hayer Postproduktion durch
Wake world München wir danken euch fürs
Zuhören bis bald euer Mirko und eure